The sky is falling! The sky is falling!
Narrator: See how these trees
sway like one single blob
in Disney's "Chicken Little"?
Compare that to this tree in "Encanto,"
where each individual leaf
moves realistically on its own.
In fact, zoom out on "Chicken Little,"
and you'll see just how little
detail is in the background
compared to Disney's newer features.
"Chicken Little" was Disney's first foray
into full 3D animation.
So the worlds the studio could
create were a lot simpler.
But animated worlds have
evolved a lot since 2005.
And one film in particular kicked off
a whole new era of realistic environments:
"Tangled."
Steve: "Tangled" really represented to me
the film where we achieved
the promise of taking the artistry
that existed at Disney Animation Studios
and applied that to the medium of CG.
Narrator: To create
the world of "Tangled,"
or any 3D-animated world,
Disney has a dedicated environments team,
whose job is to model and
develop the movie's backdrop
based on the concept designs.
The studio then uses software programs
to automatically simulate the
behavior of world elements,
like plants, water,
and lighting that illuminates it all.
To fill up the whimsical
forests of "Tangled,"
Disney developed special
tree-modeling tools
to help the environments team
lay down the geometry for lots of trees,
all with a specific fairy-tale look
that echoed the flowing shapes
of hand-drawn animation and painting.
These new tree tools included
a program called Skeletor,
which let artists hand-model 3D geometry
on certain hero trees,
like this one that Rapunzel swings from.
They also built a new
software called Dendro,
which let them art-direct the
growth of the whimsical trees
and program the direction
and amplitude of wind
in the trees' branches and leaves.
Dendro also helped calculate
how branches should grow
according to environmental factors
like gravity, light,
and natural obstacles.
The storybook trees for "Frozen"
were even more stylized than "Tangled,"
inspired by the unusual tree
design in "Sleeping Beauty."
To create these highly specific shapes
and branching structures,
Disney developed a full
vegetation generator
to replace Dendro, called Bonsai.
With Bonsai, the studio
could build a wide library
of trees, bushes, plants, and foliage
that could be shared and reused
across other Disney
productions, like "Big Hero 6."
Bonsai came in handy for
animated vegetation like this
in the film's setting of San Fransokyo.
The main challenge was
its fully urban landscape,
which stood apart from
the organic environments
seen in earlier films,
involving many more layers
of objects, movement,
and, above all, lights.
Disney needed a way to render
complex lighting environments.
Luckily, Disney engineers
were hard at work
on a powerful new
renderer called Hyperion,
which could produce densely packed scenes
with light bouncing
around in every direction,
handling several million rays at a time.
This allowed the team
to build a vibrant city,
lit in some shots
by hundreds of thousands of sources,
from streetlamps to car headlights.
That was a big leap in
terms of complexity,
in terms of the number
of individual assets
that we can actually render in one scene.
Narrator: It also helped
the filmmakers on "Moana"
capture the fanciful sense
of scale they wanted.
The name of Moana's fictional home
means, literally, "big island."
And thanks to Hyperion,
the team could produce
sunlit shots of the beach
where water simulations with
full surface reflections
extended a quarter mile into the distance
and village shots with about 10 times
the geometric complexity of San Fransokyo.
The renderer also powered over 100 shots
of the monster Te Kā,
illuminated by bright streams of lava
permeating through massive smoke plumes.
To shape the behavior of the molten lava,
Disney updated its physically
based simulator Matterhorn,
originally developed for
the snow in "Frozen."
Disney now expanded the software
to handle the more
viscous substance of lava,
along with other natural island materials
like sand, mud, and foam.
A scouting trip to Tahiti helped Larry,
the head of environments for "Moana,"
determine how each of the film's
over 60 species of vegetation
should move with the wind.
Every minute, everything was moving.
So we knew we had to do that in our movie.
Narrator: Like the fact
that coconut trees' leaflets
and bows should sway with the breeze
while the trunks themselves remain still.
For more dramatic vegetation movement
in the Te Fiti healing sequence,
the effects team created
spreading texture maps
of plant growth.
You could almost claim
that "Moana" is probably
the real progenesis of
when we started to do
really complex animated
vegetation at the studio.
Narrator: Of course, the
star of this world was water,
present in nearly every shot
and in much more complex forms
than Disney had ever produced,
including waves of all sizes
breaking in specific patterns
on the sand and reef.
So Disney developed a
new engine called Splash,
which could simulate waves running,
crashing, and breaking
and create secondary
effects like boat wakes.
But while the water in "Moana" looks warm,
crystal-clear, and inviting,
the Dark Sea in "Frozen II"
had to be rough, dark, and stormy
to convey the threats facing Elsa
as she embarks on her quest.
And I feel like we just continually
stand on our own shoulders
with the films that come before us.
So, creating the waves in "Frozen II,"
that would've been a whole
different adventure for us
if "Moana" hadn't come before that.
Narrator: So the team
shot reference footage
in parts of the Southern California coast
where the waves break especially hard.
They then used a set of equations
to model the motion of the Dark Sea waves,
experimenting with different values
for variables like amplitude
and ocean-floor depth
until they got waves
that were three to four times Elsa's size.
The artists then added more foam
and spindrift mist to capture the rough,
churned-up nature of the Dark Sea.
But the Dark Sea only marks
one stage in Elsa's quest.
Most of the film takes place
in another entirely new setting,
the Enchanted Forest, far from Arendelle.
Just as the waves had to tower over Elsa,
making her look small,
many of the shots in the
forest are framed extra-wide
to emphasize the characters' isolation,
which also puts more of
the world on display.
And since the characters
spend so much time
in this setting, Disney had to take
its forest-population
capabilities up a notch.
So it developed a new
vegetation-placement tool, Droplet.
Designed as an interactive brush,
Droplet let artists paint down, scale,
and reposition vegetation
in an art-directed way,
giving them control over the flow
and style of the forest as a whole.
The artists had to paint
not only the canopy,
but also the ground cover
in the saturated colors of autumn
in contrast to the snow-blanketed grounds
of the first movie.
Luckily, they could use
Bonsai from "Frozen I"
to manipulate the color of
the leaves on the forest floor
and to make the forest look striking
not just in overhead shots,
but from every angle.
This forest is beautiful.
Narrator: Since the snow
has melted in Arendelle,
the team had to render its buildings
in much higher detail,
increasing the texture resolution.
This visual richness was equally necessary
for the forest dam,
where surface textures
helped tell the backstory.
The filmmakers decided
that King Runeard's workers
would have to cut the stone
from the surrounding fjord walls
and assemble each block by hand.
To reinforce this idea,
artists sculpted in high-level detail
little imperfections on all the surfaces
and used texturing software
to create subtle material variation,
like these uniquely rotated
cut marks on each block.
And to show that 34 years had
passed since its construction,
artists used Droplet to
paint hundreds of thousands
of iterations of moss, grass, and mulch.
Disney continued to improve
that vegetation pipeline
for "Raya and the Last Dragon."
But the major focus was this:
the atmospherics of the
Southeast Asian settings.
These regions tend to be
dense with water and moisture,
so the environments called for
a lot of volume-based elements,
like morning mist and ground fog.
Traditionally, that work would fall
on the effects department, but in "Raya,"
instead of having the effects department
create atmospheric elements
on a per-shot basis,
Disney created these
elements in preproduction
and put them into an extensive library.
Later, as lighting artists
were lighting a shot,
they could pull from that library
and compose the atmospherics into it
without having to request new assets
from the effects department every time.
This gave the lighters more flexibility
over complex atmospheric setups
and more freedom to express
the emotional story in each scene.
Dust and smoke signified moments
of conflict and misgivings,
while trusting moments between characters
were heavier on water
elements like mist and steam.
Just as "Raya"'s Southeast Asian setting
defined its world elements,
"Encanto"'s Colombian setting
called for a lush jungle
surrounding the Madrigals' village.
And this environment had to be in motion,
like we'd see more of later
on with "Strange World,"
which was in production at
the same time as "Encanto."
Specifically, Isabela's
song is brought to life
by the whole animated environment,
with these flowering plants
growing in sync with the music.
But that dynamic environment
work was done mostly by hand.
Ben: Each artist had to go
into each and every shot
of that sequence, which
was a beautiful sequence,
and bring in custom rigs that allowed them
to do the growth for those plants.
Narrator: Disney had to figure out a way
to do that work in advance
for "Strange World,"
which, more than any other
Disney animated environment,
featured a lot of moving parts, literally.
Oh, wow.
It's beautiful!
Narrator: Elements like these plants
acted as background characters
and part of the environment
at the same time.
To set the whole landscape in motion,
the studio created an entirely new role,
animated-environments supervisor.
Ben: That role has me interacting
with almost every
department in the studio,
certainly with the
production environments team,
to ensure that the assets
that they're building
will be animatable,
and then that would move towards
effects and character animation
to provide animation for those plants,
kind of ferrying the moving plants
through the whole pipeline
one shot at a time.
Narrator: Disney also
adjusted its pipeline
so that Ben's team could fine-tune
the environments' movement
earlier on in the process.
Ben: New to this show was
the opportunity to say,
"That plant right there is
moving a little too much,"
or, "It's just a little too crazy,"
to make sure that we were handing off
the plants and the
environment in its best state
before it hit the really
render-intensive departments
such as effects and lighting,
where things start to get a
little bit harder to change.
So we would do the growing in advance,
and then when shots came,
we would place that animation in.
So all of the work was
front-loaded for "Strange World,"
which allowed us to do
many hundreds more shots
than "Encanto" did.
Narrator: The environments in this movie
weren't just dynamic. They
were some of the largest
ever created at Disney Animation,
with some stretching 2 ½ miles wide,
so large that the team needed
to expand its computing power.
Ben: At the peak, I think there was a shot
with 20 or 30 million
blades of alien grass.
Narrator: To convey the
Strange World's vastness,
the lighting team made heavy use
of atmospheric elements,
like those used for "Raya,"
adding clouds and ground fog
to create a sense of depth and scale.
These expansive sets
lent themselves to wider camera lenses.
The camera and layout team
could use controls to
adjust the lens distortion.
So whenever they wanted a shot
to feel off-kilter and, well, strange,
they could dial up the distortion effect,
a decision always driven by
the story context of the scene.
It all comes together with editing,
which gives the audience space
to take in the environment,
and sound design, which helps communicate
the character of the space.
[buzzing and crackling]
Sarah: Because, you know,
it doesn't have a face,
it can't communicate that way,
but it can communicate through sound.
It's squishy, it breathes.
I make sure that there's
an intentional personality
behind every little sound
that the plants make
as they breathe in or
breathe out or undulate.
Narrator: Now that Disney's
built such a powerful tool set
for living, breathing worlds,
the team has to step it back sometimes,
especially since, unlike
live-action-film makers,
they're creating these
worlds from the ground up.
In feature animation, sort
of the sky's the limit,
and you can easily put
more in than you need.
You're looking for that perfect blend
of organic, fascinating
texture in the background,
not so much that it's going to take away
from what the characters are doing,
what the characters are saying.
Narrator: After all, Disney builds worlds
to service the story,
not the other way around.
For the same reason,
it doesn't stick to any
house style for world design,
instead tailoring each
world to its story needs.
Just contrast the details of the castles
in "Tangled" and "Frozen."
Steve: Rapunzel's tower, the wooden beams,
there isn't a straight beam anywhere.
Everything's handcrafted, hand-hewn,
everything's got a slight twist
and an organic feel to it,
riffing off of the design principles
that applied to "Snow
White" and "Pinocchio."
When you look at the interiors
of the castle in "Frozen,"
we do have a lot of very
straight, rigid lines,
and that's, of course, all done to support
what we're saying about
those environments.
Oh, this is for royalty.
OK, they were getting the best craftsmen,
who could make the straightest line.
And really everything needs to go through
that level of rigor and discussion.
Narrator: Those decisions
on "Strange World"
struck a balance between
making the landscape
feel imaginative and unexpected
while retaining the story-first principle
that made the classic
Disney movies so beloved.